christoph hat heute morgen leider seine
stimme verloren deshalb übernehme ich
die heutige folge und zwar mit diesem
thema künstliche intelligenz in vielen
filmen und büchern werden k s oft als
übermächtige computerprogramme
dargestellt die die gesamte menschheit
auslöschen wollen
doch wie real sind diese szenarien
wirklich und wie können wir uns dagegen
schützen
die antwort gibt es jetzt bei clixoom
science fiction
wer von euch schon mal ein
computerprogramm selber geschrieben hat
weiß man muss den computer präzise sagen
was in welcher reihenfolge ausgeführt
werden soll macht man dabei auch nur
einen kleinen fehler dann ist das
programm oft nicht fähig überhaupt zu
starten
wie also bringt man einem solchen
programm bei selbstständig zu denken
sich weiterzuentwickeln oder sogar
aufgaben zu lösen von dem man selber gar
keine ahnung hat wie man sie lösen kann
im jahr 1956 hat sich der elektro
ingenieur us-serie die aufgabe gestellt
diesen computer so zu programmieren dass
er ihn im checkers schlagen würde
um das zu bewerkstelligen kam ihm eine
brillante idee er ließ den computer
tausende male gegen sich selber spielen
dadurch sammelte die maschine erfahrung
die in form von regeln gespeichert wurde
und es funktionierte schon sechs jahre
später konnte der computer den
landesmeister von connecticut im
checkers besiegen
die maschine war ein riesenerfolg und
damals eine sensation es war die erste
bekannte form eines selbstlernenden
prozesses der von menschen gemacht wurde
doch wo stehen wir heute wenn es um
künstliche intelligenz geht dieser
japanische supercomputer war vor drei
jahren der schnellste computer auf der
welt in einer zusammenarbeit zwischen
deutschen und japanischen forschern
simulierte man mit über 1000 millionen
berechnungen pro sekunde ein
menschliches gehirn
naja man simulierte ein eines
menschlichen gehirns und für diese eine
sekunde aktivität musste der
supercomputer 40 minuten lang rechnen
das gehirn ist unglaublich komplex
allerdings bedeutet das nicht dass der
computer nicht das gleiche könnte wie
wir menschen auch mit dem sogenannten
deep learning können algorithmen symbole
und konzepte verstehen
im jahr 2012 ließ google einen solchen
algorithmus auf zehntausende von
youtube-videos los am ende konnte der
computer mit einer genauigkeit von
immerhin 70 prozent katzen und menschen
erkennen ohne dass ihm jemals etwas über
katzen oder menschen bei gebracht wurde
der algorithmus lernte komplett
selbstständig aus den youtube videos
google nutzt diesen algorithmus heute um
ähnliche bilder im netz finden zu können
aber wir menschen sind natürlich immer
noch besser im verstehen und vor allem
im interpretieren von bildern oder naja
dieser benchmark test für bilderkennung
algorithmen zeigt dass die beste
software die es jetzt schon heute gibt
doppelt so gut im erkennen von
straßenschildern ist als ein
durchschnittlicher deutscher autofahrer
der ibm computer watson schlägt die
beiden besten jeopardy spieler der welt
im rapper die und ist beinahe
unbesiegbar in der pokervariante texas
hold'em nicht nur findet er auf fast
jede quizfrage selbstständig eine
antwort er versteht auch was der
quizmaster ihnen gerade gefragt hat und
antwortet in grammatikalisch korrekte
und manchmal sogar witzigen setzen
selbst lernende computer können also
heute schon sehen lesen antworten und
dazulernen
für viele menschen ist so schwierig sich
vorzustellen dass die eigene arbeit
einmal von einer maschine ersetzt werden
soll
meine arbeit ist doch viel zu komplex
für einen computer wir können die das
denn jemals hinkriegen
doch laut einer studie sind in den
meisten ländern über 80 prozent der
arbeitsplätze so genannte service
arbeitsplätze deren hauptaufgabe es ist
zu sehen lesen und zu antworten also
genau das was computer nun seit kurzem
immer besser beherrschen
die größte gefahr die von einem selbst
lernende computer ausgeht ist also die
der großen arbeitslosigkeit und das sind
nicht nur die jobs für die keine
akademische bildung benötigt wird
sogar ärzte und anwälte müssen in
zukunft richtig aufpassen einen
präzedenzfall aus tausenden von fällen
finden oder eine diagnose stellen die
alle symptome des patienten
berücksichtigt dass könnten computer
bald wesentlich effizienter erledigen
als intelligente menschen mit einem uni
abschluss und im gegensatz zur
industriellen revolution wird es um
einiges schwieriger sein für diese
menschen einen alternativen arbeitsplatz
zu finden selbst lernende algorithmen
breiten sich in alle bereiche der
gesellschaft aus ohne neue arbeitsplätze
zu schaffen
das wird eines der größten politischen
probleme der nächsten 50 jahre sein ende
maske wird oft mit dem comic heldin
verglichen
er ist gründer von unternehmen wie
spacex über das wir ja hier bei pixum
häufiger berichten paypal und tesla
motors
und er ist ein pionier auf dem gebiet
der zukunftsträchtigen und
weitreichenden projekte laut allen masc
ist die künstliche intelligenz eine
gefährlichere erfindung für die
menschheit als die atombombe
er investiert in viele unternehmen die
sich mit dem thema beschäftigen um ein
auge auf die branche zu werfen laut el
más künstliche intelligenz solange kein
problem solange man vorsichtig und mit
sagt vorgeht
aber es braucht nur einen kleinen staat
mit bösen absichten oder eine mächtige
organisation um fatalen schaden
anzurichten
programme die sich ständig selbst
umschreiben verbessern und reproduzieren
können das internet und alles was damit
verbunden ist kontrollieren aber auch
ohne böse absichten kann ein software
fehler oder ein unbedachter teil einer
solchen künstlichen intelligenz
verheerend außer kontrolle laufen
zugegeben das klingt jetzt hier alle
sehr nach science und fiction film doch
ein offener brief des future of life
institut warnte nun genau davor
man müsse die positiven möglichkeiten
dieser programme erforschen
gleichzeitig aber auch die potenzielle
gefahr dahinter unter kontrolle halten
der offenen brief wurde von nicht einmal
zwei wochen veröffentlicht hat aber
jetzt schon von tausenden von
wissenschaftlern und forschern
unterschriften erhalten alle haben
großen respekt vor den möglichen
auswirkungen von künstlicher intelligenz
unter den unterschriften geben befindet
sich auch stephen hawking der selber nur
durch einen intelligenten computer
kommunizieren kann allen masc ist auch
dabei über den haben ja gerade
gesprochen und das entwicklerteam von
ibm das den computer watson programmiert
hat die gefahren die von diesen
algorithmen ausgeht ist der sogenannte
schneeballeffekt je mehr das programm
weiß desto schneller lernt ist neue
dinge dazu im exponentiellen tempo ist
die maschine intelligenter als ein
mensch und ein programmierte regeln
könnten vom programm selber
umgeschrieben werden
oder anders interpretiert werden wie zb
verhindert eine maschine das einem
menschen schaden zugefügt wird
vielleicht indem sie verhindert dass der
mensch überhaupt geboren wird
es ist schwer zu sagen was eine solche
maschine denkt und wie sie zur
menschheit stehen wird aber im endeffekt
wäre die maschinen und intellektuell so
überlegen wie wir es im moment tieren
sind und unser schicksal würde von mir
abhängen sowie das schicksal von affen
oder hunden im moment von uns abhängt
genauso überlegen sind uns
wahrscheinlich aliens für den fall dass
wir einmal auf außerirdische treffen
werden jetzt schon vorbereitungen
getroffen
mehr zu diesem spannenden thema einfach
in diesem video aliens vorbereitung auf
den ersten kontakt alle infos und noch
zusätzliche spannende videos zum thema
künstliche intelligenz findet ihr wie
immer in der video beschreibung zum blog
und zuerst geht's wie immer hier unten
und was denkt ihr werden computer bald
die macht über uns erhalten oder können
wir die algorithmen kontrollieren und
sie zu unserem vorteil nutzen diskutiert
es wie immer mit uns unten in den
kommentaren und ansonsten bin ich
natürlich auch sehr gespannt auf
feedback für mich wie ich das video ist
hier gerade gemacht habe würde mich auf
jeden fall sehr freuen
ansonsten sage ich vielen dank fürs
zuschauen bis zum nächsten mal patrick